[Music]
hello my name is ugh lamkula and today
my colleague beatrice roldan
and i are going to introduce you into
the research we are conducting
at the cluster of excellence unizuskat
which is coordinated by the technical
university of berlin
our research cluster combines scientists
including senior and union scientists
which are working at the three
universities in berlin the university of
potsdam
the charity and the research institutes
free mpe cargi hudson b and fmp
at the berlin brandenburg area
and the research combines highly
interdisciplinary
research areas including molecular
biology structural biology chemistry
physics and theory
[Music]
under the topic revolutionizing
catalysis we are going to introduce our
cluster of excellence unesses cut
first there's going to be a introductory
lecture by our speaker arne thomas
and he's going to be giving a basic
introduction to the research done in
this
in this area then we are going to have
expert talks by several scientists
within the cluster
we want to give you the an idea of the
excellent office springs that we have in
our cluster
for example junior professor francisca
hess and also
tobias gaines and marius hall are going
to be giving
giving a presentation of their work
another topic within the berlin science
science week that
we would like to contribute to is to
raise awareness about gender issues in
science
and in this case we are going to have
expert talks and we are going to have a
debate
and we have uh innis weidinger marie
andrea morwinsky
and professor lankula and myself are
going to be
talking in this area in particular how
what was our pathway to become a
professor and
at the end we are going to have also an
interview and
some discussion about on our topic of
research in this case
how to go from carbon dioxide
to the production that is a greenhouse
house to the greenhouse gas
to the production of chemicals and fuels
[Music]
yeah so i'm a biologist a biochemist
and our research is conducted with
enzymes
enzymes are proteins which are composed
of 21 amino acids
and we are trying to use these enzymes
to fix
co2 and to produce some
reusable fuels what we call it to
convert them to
compounds which then can be used as an
energy source
this concept exists in nature already
um i guess everyone knows about
photosynthesis which enables life on
earth and photosynthesis carbon dioxide
is fixed
then to produce oxygen and
sugar compounds but we are now trying
to use this concept in a
smaller scale and to use these enzymes
and to fix
co2
[Music]
so i'm working in the electrochemical
conversion of
carbon dioxide two chemicals and fuels
and the the idea is that both have
both of us have the same goal we want to
to take a greenhouse gas and convert it
into something useful
and he her approach is based on
biological materials my approach is
based
on on inorganic materials but we all
both to do artificial photosynthesis we
both want to close the the carbon cycle
and be able to so we know very well how
to take hydrocarbons and fuels and burn
them
and to make co2 what we need to learn
now is how to take this co2
and convert it back to something useful
in this case in my research we are
trying to make
hydrocarbons and fuels for example
ethanol or ethylene
ethylene is being used to make polymers
to make for example
a packaging and ethanol is used as a
source of energy
okay so chemically co2 is quite a stable
compound it's inert
how we call it and it is requires a lot
of energy input to convert it then
to other compounds which we then can use
as fuel
in biology the nature has used i mean
during evolution has optimized systems
and so in biology co2 can be
fixed under ambient temperature
and in cells then with the usage of the
energy provided by the cell and produced
by this head
so in the case of electrochemical co2
conversion
what we are trying to do is to use a
renewable energy in this case for
example
solar energy or wind energy as an energy
source to produce electricity
and to make this process actually
interesting for an at industrial level
we should have cheap electricity and
this has been achieved in the in the
recent years
the whole process requires the energy as
in this case solar wind energy as
a source we want to go from carbon
dioxide to products that are going to be
of industrial value for example making
ethanol or making hydrocarbons
and we are going to use inorganic
materials maybe the the advantage of
inorganic materials versus some of the
biological materials could be that they
are more stable
and it is possible also to regenerate
them at the industrial setting on site
and stability is one of the key problems
in catalysis selectivity and stability
but i believe that both of our projects
are very complementary because in both
cases
i'm trying also to learn what nature
does because nature is already doing
photosynthesis for
many many years and right now we are
trying to develop catalysts that are
going to be doing what the
photosynthesis catalyst in nature are
doing
[Music]
so in electrochemical co2 reduction
the idea is for example at the moment we
are producing a lot of energy
electrical energy through renewable
energy but this energy
is intermittent so you can you are not
able to use it when it's produced
and it's not always being produced as
much as we need and sometimes we have
excess
if you are able to take this energy and
on site
use it for an for another process in
this case to drive an electrochemical
process this electricity
is basically used as the energy source
to convert co2 this very stable molecule
into something useful
and the energy that we have at the
moment is
renewable energy then you can have a
process that will be a
zero carbon process so you can go from
co2
without producing more co2 into
something valuable
i mean the answer is yes we we think so
because
um that's why we are working on this
but it is of course challenging and but
there are first examples already
provided by nature on a
biotechnology biotechnology level
um there are organisms which can fix
co2 to acetate without
using the sunlight so in a
non-photosynthetic process
and even they can then convert the co2
not only
to acetate but also to methanol and
first companies are using this process
it's not so efficient
but i mean in our research we are trying
not to use the whole in our whole cell
system we are
trying to use enzymes we want to
stabilize the enzymes
and then to make them efficient that
co2 can be fixed into other organic
compounds
yeah so we are using enzymes which exist
already in the cell which were evolved
by nature but the enzymes we are using
so far are not working in the direction
of
co2 reduction of co2 fixation
they are doing the opposite reaction
um they produce co2 from formate so the
enzymes we are working with are called
formate dehydrogenases
and in our work we would like to
engineer them in a way
that they do the reverse reaction that
they do as i said co2
reduction it is working already
so enzymes exist we are just trying to
make
this reaction more efficient at the
moment
and co2 is converted into methanol for
example
through a hydrogenation process in this
case normally they are using hydrogen
that is not green hydrogen it's a
hydrogen
they call it blue so it's produced based
on fossil fuels
and this process is very requires a lot
of energy
it happens at high pressure and about
250 300 celsius
the idea of now finding an alternative
process in this case the electrochemical
conversion of co2
so now we don't need to apply high
pressure we can do this
this reaction at atmospheric pressure we
can do it
in water and the only thing that we need
is to have electricity
for many years electricity was expensive
so this process was not induced very
viable
but now through the use of renewable
energy through the
the possibility of employing excess
solar or wind energy that we will have
we are going to be able to take co2 and
convert this molecule into other high
value products for example making
hydrocarbons such as
ethylene or making a fuel such as
ethanol
so i think um the electrochemical
production of either hydrogen
or going from co2 to hydrocarbons and
fuels these are very complementary
processes it's not one or the other
it's very important that we work towards
both processes
the beauty of this is that we can work
in in a
complementary way so you can develop the
same
electrochemical cells the same
electrolyzer for both processes
so all the engineering all of this
development will be the same
when you want to use hydrogen as a fuel
i think this is a very important process
my
research group is also working on this
but i see this more a little bit long
term
the co2 electrochemical reduction can be
done in a smaller scale
and can be done on site for example we
have a lot of industry
that is already producing co2 at the
moment in highly concentrated manner
and without changing any of the
infrastructure we could start with a
small scale co2 electrolyzers
to take this concentrated co2 on site
and convert it into for example a fuel
like ethanol or ethylene
this doesn't mean that we shouldn't be
doing electrolysis
from water to hydrogen we need to do
that too but there we might need to have
a little bit more infrastructural
changes
and i think if we work with both
processes in parallel we can take
advantage of everything that we learn in
terms of electrolyzer technology
that we are developing for hydrogen
economy as well as
to convert the the greenhouse gas co2
into something valuable
we can combine all of this knowledge so
i believe we need to do both
and they have very different very
different applications so if we can
do things on site where we are producing
the co2
this is going to be marketable and there
are a number of industries in germany
that are already
going towards this call for co2
electrochemical conversion
and i think they will be short-term
versus the hydrogen that we need
a little bit more major infrastructural
changes
[Music]
the next level is maybe to go to more
complex systems
so one goal in our research project is
to
then couple different enzymes to use
um hydrogen as energy source
and to couple hydrogenase with our
format dehydrogenase
or to couple photosystem which is
performing i mean which is using the
energy from the sunlight and that
then as an energy source for the co2
reduction process
[Music]
a very important challenge is that in
both cases we need water for the
electrolyte
and a very important challenge is how to
get water that is clean enough
when we are doing water splitting for
hydrogen production
ideally you want to do this with water
from the ocean
because this is readily available and in
many of the processes that we are
we are working with the main challenge
is that we need to have water
that will be a good electrolyte and most
of the water is too dirty to be able to
to be used as as it is
[Music]
the the type of the an electrochemical
process
has different steps first of all you
need to have this
your source in this case will be co2 and
it's very challenging to get co2 from
the atmosphere and concentrate it
it's possible to do it but it's
expensive so the
first applications that we are going to
see is when we are have for example a
cement plant
where we already have very large amounts
of co2 concentrated on site
we don't need to spend any any energy to
to to concentrate it
and this is going to be our source of
co2 this is also in meals and in many of
the industrial processes that we have
currently
then the second step we need energy and
the energy here we are working at
atmospheric pressure but we need
energy in terms of electricity so we
need to be able to
to have access in this case to clean
energy renewable energy so we need the
low solar or wind energy then we need to
have an electrolyzer
so the technology the the the reactor
the device for the electrolysis
is actually not very complex but we know
we need
we know right now very well how to do
this at the lav scale
but if we want to scale this up we need
to develop also this technology so we
have a problem of scaling up what we
know very well how to do in the lab
so this will be the reactor and then at
the core is the catalyst
so we need to develop very active
selective catalysts
that are simple to synthesize so that
this will be of industrial relevance if
we need
100 steps to synthesize the catalyst no
industry is going to be able to follow
this process
so we need a catalyst that is going to
be made out of earth abundant materials
we need a catalyst that is going to be
simple to make
it will be low cost and ideally you
should be able to regenerate it
yes with the enzyme systems we will try
to fix
the co2 from the atmosphere to produce a
compound that can be then used as a fuel
and then again emit co2 to the
atmosphere
but this is a closed cycle so we will
not uh then
produce more co2 so in the long term
range
the global co2 concentration will be
reduced so enzyme systems will
contribute to that
but not as i said only in the long term
range
and it's an occlused cycle
i think the the idea that we have we
will be really happy if we can
stop the the very rapid increase in the
in the earth temperature
so we have a goal of staying below 2
degrees increase
and i think there is already very clear
scientific evidence that the
concentration of co2
in the atmosphere has a correlation with
the increase in the temperature
of our planet so this is already a given
now anything that we can do
to to minimize this is something that
scientists will have this
this very important task for the next
generation
there are different aspects that we can
address one of one aspect is
we can address through trying to
minimize co2 emissions
for example going to processes as we
mentioned before
and changing the the energy to to
sources that would be such as hydrogen
and so
something that is not going to be
involved forcing fuels this is one
aspect
the other aspect is we cannot stop all
the industrial work that we have right
now and especially we don't need to
think only about the developed countries
we need to think also about the
underdeveloped countries where you
cannot say stop completing your industry
and
and we will give you some point a
technology to make hydrogen
so given that we also have this
problematic we need to have alternatives
and
the idea of on-site being able to
convert the co2 that we are producing
and that we will be producing steel for
a number of years
electrochemically into something useful
that can be used also on site
i think this is a very attractive idea i
don't believe that this is going to
solve our climate change problem i
believe that our solution is really go
to
going towards a hydrogen economy but i
think it's not one or the other is
one and the other and we need to think
about short term what we can do right
now
and there are already industries doing
this you are they are already trying to
how to make use of this concentrated co2
and there are different processes you
can do it electrochemically but you also
can do it through thermal catalysis in
my group we are working on both aspects
and at some point they are going to be a
mix of thermal catalysis processes
and electrochemical processes and
ideally it will be something that you
can switch from one to the other for
example if electricity becomes more
expensive then it may be more
interesting to do a thermal catalysis
process even if you have to use
more energy in terms of high pressure
and when the electricity prices are low
then you will switch to
the production of a certain chemical
based on electrochemical process
and i think catalysis is at the core of
everything that we have in our daily
life
so if you think about most of the
products that you're using daily
at some point a catalyst was used and
and whether you are you are doing this
with cerebral catalysis through
electrochemistry through biological
catalysis
i think this is something that is really
really
very important for the development of
our society
[Music]
so in the field of co2 electron
reduction there is a very strong link
now to biology there are already
a number of research groups and even
industry interested in using
algae for example as a catalyst and so
there is a lot of interest in combining
also organic and inorganic
systems and using also things that
nature give us
as a electrocatalyst so i believe that
there is a lot of synergy between these
aspects of catalysis
i studied biology and the other level i
mean
of a woman during those studies was much
more than than
men i think it was about 50 percent
but it leveled out a little bit later
then
at the moment i think my at my
university in potsdam
i'm at the biochemistry and biology
department we have 40
female professors so the university is
doing a good job in hiring women so when
i when i
started my career in spain there was not
a big difference between number of
female studying in physics it was 60
male 40 female but this changed when i
moved to the us and this has
dramatically changed when i moved to
germany
so i was the only female professor in
the physics department at the rural
university warhol
when i joined and then when i when i
became a director of the freestyle
institute i was the first female
director in the history
so this is over 100 years so there is a
it is a big change i don't see a
difference between female and male
scientists in terms of you know i always
talk to colleagues and it doesn't matter
what type of colleague i'm talking to
but it is at times difficult to
to convey the idea to of of the younger
generation that
there are certain jobs that are not more
male oriented or more female oriented
when
when you start talking to little girls
and and little boys
i think it should be very natural to
become a scientist and it shouldn't
matter what gender you are if you want
to become a scientist
[Music]
you